MERZLIKINS COMING OFF A LOSS
AGAINST
BLUE JACKETS, IT COMES ALL THE
WAY IN ON MERZLIKINS.
HE WILL PLAY TU ARE LOOKING AT
JOHANSSON IN GAME NUMBER 700.
CE-OFF IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
GEEKIE WINS THE DRAW.
HERE'S DONSKOI HAS IT.
WILL PLAY IT TO THROUGH
PERIOD ONE.
GIORDANO.AD
STOPPED BY MERZLI
A LITTLE SAUCER PASS FOR
WERENSKI.
MERZLIKINS.T ON DEN
GABRIEL OLEKSIAK.
TIPPED WIDE BY McCANN OFF THE
SIDE OF THE GOAL. THIS COLUMBUS
MANPOWER ADVANTAGE.
MAX DOMI BJORKSTRAND.
JORKSTRAND
THERE AT THE FACE-OFF DOT HAS AN
OPEN SHOT.
THE GUY CAN REALLY S FRONT.
THEY SCORE!
JACK ROSLOVIC GOT THE INSIDHEAD.
PERFECT PASS ON THE EDGE.
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TIME WITH LWAYS
THE SHOT IS BUT JUST GETTING
HE WILL SCORE!
MAX DOMI WILL STRETCHUT THEN YO
SEE DOMI TAKE OFF.
A NICE LITTLE SKILL PLAY,
THROUGH THE LEGS.
THEY SCORE!
IT LEAKS THROUGH AND IT IS POKED
HOME, AND, AGAIN, IN DOWN.
IT ALLOWS BJORKSTRANDSCORES!
JOONAS DONSKOI!
PICKS YOU
STAND IN FRONT.
TAKEN AWAY GOES FROM
HERE.
GEEKIE IS RIGHT VINCE DUNN.
KURALY TRAPS THE ZONE.
DUNNEATTLE.
OLEKSIAK, OVERSKATED A BIT.
JENNER OUT IN FRONT.
IT KICROUGH CENTER.
PASS, SCHWARTZ THE OUTSIDE.
CAN DO.
WHEN HE GETS UP INTO THE PLAY,
HE HAS THAT SHOT.
THE OFFENSIVE ICE.
DANFORTH MOVES ENDS.
GET THE LONG CHANGE IN
GIORDANO MOVES IT AROUND.
THE SHOT.ARDED BY
HE SCORES!
JAKE BEAN GOES